欢迎各位处理今天这期摆车圈说。
我是三刀
今天这期节目咱们来聊一聊五月份刚刚上市的华金S。
我们突文也有
我们视频也有
今天咱们音频把它补上。
好好去聊一聊这个车到底值不值得买。
这个车为什么现在还挂着保镜的标。
这个车将来会不会品牌独立。
然后质价到底仓内的激光雷达。
华为的乾坤质价好不好用。
等等
大家只要是想买这个车。
我觉得绝大部分你关心的问题。
重点的问题
今天这一期应该都能聊得到。
我最近也是会有一期别人研究车。
而我研究你的视频会上线。
大概要再过一个星期。
我今天音频节目就讲的再细一点。
我相信你听完之后。
对华金这个品牌到底是怎么回事。
它跟保镜之间什么关系。
跟武林什么关系
跟隔壁的什么起进。
意境之间是什么关系。
应该就非常的清楚了。
这车有什么优点
有什么缺点
什么配置应该学
那么刚开始这车上市的时候。
很多人还有些质疑。
说武林对吧？
造这么大个车
然后还用华为的这么一个支架。
支仓
全家统
卖这么便宜
说你看5月份也没卖得很好。
5月份虽然不是一个完整的一个月。
它是5月8号上市的。
那么陆陆续续的到正式交付。
也就相当于才卖了三个星期左右。
三周的销量卖了3603台。
感觉也不咋地
然后到了6月份卖了5689台。
好像也不咋地
那么到了7月份卖了7203台。
这个时候有些人反映过来了。
相当于它的销量是跟着产能走的。
没有哪台车子说上来的销量能。
短短的两个月能翻一倍。
从3600放到7200。
你这个车子刚开始卖得不好。
那就卖得不好
你怎么会突然之间。
两个月销量翻一倍。
那很明显就是产能在提升。
所以它的8月份的销量。
预估应该是能破万了。
我网上也有人猜
因为官方没有公布正式的数据。
也有人各方面的去推算。
它的提升时间
现在这个车基本上订车。
有的地方快有的地方慢。
我看有的地方慢的话要到一个多月。
快的话
有的人可能一周两周就能提到车了。
那么有人说订单量大概是在。
目前厂家整体的接单量。
大概是在6万张
有人说是8万张
不管到具体几万张。
反正这车肯定是卖的还不错。
绝对不可能一个月就五六千的这么一个销量。
所以我估计8月份的销量应该是在1万上下。
它目前明显是销量是跟着产能在走。
它是在提升产能的这样一个阶段。
好 我们就展开来聊一聊这个车。
那关于华靖这个品牌。
我估计大多数人应该是不太了解的。
最近这一两年也冒出来很多的镜。
像我前面提到的除了华靖。
还有起镜 异镜
那么哪个是武林的。
哪个是广汽的
哪个是东风的
大家能对得上吗？
我估计很多人一时半伙都对不上。
因为你毕竟你不是天天研究汽车的。
我教你个最简单的方法。
武林 华靖你就想武林。
就是叫什么叫
人民需要什么？
武林就造什么？
中华的子民
对吧 中华的子民需要什么？
武林就造什么？
所以华靖
华靖就是武林的
那么异镜为什么是东风的。
因为东风有个异派。
东风异派这个名字。
我相信大多数人还是知道的。
如果异派你都不知道。
异镜的名字确实你不太好记。
因为东风有异派
所以异镜相当于它就属于东风系的。
起镜更好记了
因为广汽 广汽 异镜。
广汽的气和异镜的气。
两个相当于是谐音。
所以广汽是起镜
东风是异镜
然后武林是华镜
所以只能是这么计。
然后你再想一想
这些什么华镜起镜异镜。
它们分别下面会有什么车型呢？
有些人已经开始有点记不清了。
那么每个车型分别是定位于SUV。
还是轿车 还是轿跑。
还是旅行车 机梯车型什么的。
大家就更讲不清楚了。
每个车型分别是定位多少万。
大概什么价位段
十几万还是二十几万的。
大家就开始蒙了
所以第一时间
你手头如果有个十几 二十几万的预算。
你说能够想到去买这三个镜的。
那毕竟还是少数
还是少数
所以你像华镜
它也是投了很多广告。
对吧？
你像我打篮球的球场。
我就能看到它的广告。
还有一些机场也能看到广告。
它们的广告力度非常大。
然后也是各种各样的。
就是曝光
让大家至少知道
有这么一个车型
有华为的质价
然后价格卖的相对来讲还比较低。
十几万就能买到一个5米2几。
轴距超过3米1的。
这么一个带华为质价的SUV。
就是你解释的越少。
你的销量越高
那么其他的几个镜。
其实说句实在话
你需要让大家去买你这个车。
你需要解释的成本会更高一起。
所以怎么说呢？
就是华镜跟华为的合作。
武林的这样的一个模式。
现在目前跑的还是比较通的。
但是它的这个模式跟起镜。
异镜跟华为的合作模式还不太一样。
所以我说后面会详细去讲一讲。
它们之间的这种合作的方式。
有什么不同
因为我觉得还是需要花点篇幅的。
先前面暂时不展开。
展开的话
有些人对这个声音还不是太了解。
我一会再讲一讲这个车的数据。
那么最后就是关于这个车的价格。
我刚刚前面说了
这个车最大的卖点是什么？
就是把一台在舱内激光雷达的。
华为智能座舱智能驾驶的。
这么一个超过5米2的大型插孔SUV。
把它价格直接达到了15万以内。
它的起诉价格只要14万9000。
那么大家肯定是看到这个价格就要惊呼。
说这个价格无敌之前没见过。
你之前真的没见过145万的车。
5米2左右或者5米出头的这样一个尺寸的。
肯定是有的
像什么东风1008。
零跑的C16
还有银河的M9这些车。
虽然说尺寸不一定有它那么大。
但是都是5米上下。
也是达这个价位的。
就价格其实跟它都差不多。
人家唯独没有能拿得出手的这么一个杀手锦。
就是华为的这样一个最新版本的支架。
在舱内激光雷达的支架。
所以这车的卖点非常的清晰。
就不用多解释
那么网上一边有的人去夸。
说价格无敌 性价比无敌。
但是另外一边也有人揍着眉头很担心。
说你价格打得这么低。
哇 你真的这么厉害 这么牛逼吗？
有没有可能你不仅仅降价 你还降质。
就是你的质量是不是有点不太行。
是不是在看不见的地方。
你脱工减料了
我觉得不要着急
你如果就要在今年年底之前买。
你可以在网上等一段时间看看有没有拆车报告。
底盘拆开来之后给你去分析这里那里。
有没有去脱工减料的。
如果确确实实拆开来之后。
发现这里面的这些材料都不行。
那你可以选择Pass。
这是第一阶段
第二阶段是什么呢？
那你就去听真实车主的反馈。
你可以在车制榜里面去看投诉名单。
到底有没有人去大量投诉这个车。
然后第二个你可以在小红书上面你搜维权。
你过个一年 过个半年。
你就直接搜这个车维权。
你就搜这个车质量问题。
你就搜这个车型
滑进S空格维修
滑进S空格质量不行。
滑进S空格吐槽
反正你就售后
反正这些词你就往你加。
你加完之后你看网上。
有没有共性的问题。
如果只是这个人说不行。
那个人说不行
每个人说的问题都不一样。
如果每一个人只有一次两次出现。
我觉得这不算共性的。
如果大量的都说
这个车比方讲左前玻璃。
上下的升降器
总是会有意想
如果你发一搜十几条权这样。
那就说明这肯定是个共性问题。
对吧？
所以你要如果实在担心。
你至少得过个半年以上。
一年以上
你想它一个月的销量。
现在就五六千七八千台。
你等它稳定在一个月一万台。
你再过个半年
这个车子在市面上有交付差不多十万辆。
七八万辆 八九万辆。
这个时候才会
你按照这个比例算。
才会有一部分的车主。
它至少也得用个三五千公里。
我觉得你一千公里再网上你就写报告了。
也不可能
三五千公里
或者说是万八公里。
这个时候开始有些人出现一些小问题了。
它就会去在网上吐槽。
所以我个人建议就是这样。
你要如果实在担心。
那你就等
你又担心又想买
那没有什么好的方法。
目前来讲
你只能是看一些拆车报告。
但是拆车说句实在话。
解读的空间也是非常大的。
是吧？
那么网上还有一种声音是什么？
说这个车它挂着保镜的标。
它到底是华静还是保镜。
那么关于华静S到底属于。
华静还是属于保镜。
我先提前讲一句话。
就是这个项目立项的时候。
其实它还叫保镜华镜S。
但是等它正式上市了一段时间之后。
就把前面的保镜去掉了。
然后在它的官网里面。
它相当于就是把现在的华静。
是作为上期通用武林旗下的一个新品牌。
是跟武林红标
武林营标
还有保镜
它是并列在上期武林的品牌体系里面的。
所以你现在问我说。
这个华静到底是一个品牌。
还是说华静S只是一款车。
我可以明确告诉你。
就是因为上期武林已经把它的品牌。
是独立出来了
那么一会我再详细来讲。
这里面还有故事
所以不是一句两句能说完的。
我一会给你详细解释一下。
就到底它跟保镜跟武林之间是什么个关系。
这个华静的身份确实挺复杂。
我们接下来先简单讲一讲。
就关于这款车
它的一些详细的参数。
因为很多人听到现在就一块10分钟了。
还是不太了解这车的具体的一些。
相关的参数
因为有些人可能想买。
那么首先华静S这个车定位是大型的X红SUV。
因为它的车长已经是到了5235。
超过了5米2
然后宽度是1999。
是接近于2米
车高是1米8
整个车的其实车身高度也挺高的。
然后轴距是3105。
是超过了3米1
它是一个标准的相当于叫532。
就是9系
大家知道市面上现在9系就是532。
车长超过5米
轴距超过3米
然后宽度接近2米。
就是532这么一个布局。
然后车目前只有插电热混合动力。
所以有的人问说有没有纯电。
我觉得真的是挺有意思的。
有纯电车的时候
大家就说这车有没有插火。
有没有增尘
人家只出了一个插火。
又问这车有没有纯电。
还有人家说如果是增尘就好了。
我就想买增尘
我真的是服了
然后这个车目前是2加2加2的6座布局。
也只有目前这一个布局形式。
好了
网友又说了6座不行。
我想要骑座
还有人网友说我不想要6座。
我想要5座
你能不能出个5座版本。
官方的微博跟官方小红书也很有意思。
他基本上这些问题他都会回。
然后他说你放心后期有纯电。
然后对方就网友不回复了。
然后还有人讲说有5座我就买。
他说你放心后面有5座。
然后网友又不回复了。
这5座他后面也是有的。
然后纯电版本他后面也是会有的。
那么尺寸其实拿来去跟文件的M9。
对比的话文件M9的长宽高是5285。
车宽是2020 26。
高度是1845
轴距是3125
所以你跟刚刚前面我们说的这个数据比起来的话。
两台车都是超过了5米2。
只不过差那么几公分。
一个是5235
一个是5285
宽度因为M9是超过了2米。
也只是超了一丢丢。
然后我们说的华金S是1999接近2米。
对吧？
那么轴距一个是3105。
一个是3125
也就是差了20毫米相当于是2公分。
所以你可以这么理解。
就是华金S跟文件M9的尺寸是相差无极的。
那肯定就属于同级车型。
但是它绝对不是同级竞品。
因为华金S相当于是三折左右的文件M9。
因为文件M9起步就是40多万。
再往上50多万
60多万
如果是相当于是限量版那种就80多万了。
那就更夸张了
所以M9的价格的跨度真的是非常的大。
非常的大
那么因此一个只卖到149800。
到18万多的
这样的一款尺寸跟文件M9接近于是一样的。
同时还有仓内激光雷达。
有华为支架的这么一款车。
你说这个车的性价比到底怎样。
我真的我觉得其他配置都不用讲了。
那么大家都知道隔壁的理想。
它有一个叫半价理想的影子品牌。
就一直是蹭它流量的影子品牌。
是谁
不用说大家都知道对吧？
全体起立
领跑
但是领跑汽车蹭的还挺成功的。
因为你看它最近一个月的交付量。
它能超过10万台。
非常夸张
就是新实力车企里面。
对吧？
就不像我们之前讲的像齐锐。
吉利比亚迪这种
就是新实力里面能够单月交付量超10万的。
目前还是第一个
所以领跑是半价理想。
那领跑是半价理想。
谁是半价的问街呢？
谁是半价的鸿蒙制型呢？
大家都知道鸿蒙制型的车。
很多人其实想要想买的。
想要华为的支架
想要华为的全家统。
但是就是太贵了
起步的价格都很贵的。
好了
那么现在出了一个华进。
华进说
我的价格就是三折的问街M9嘛？
对不对
我不是半价问街
我是三折问街
三折问街
有点意思啊？
是不是有点意思
所以我讲他们就是两拨客户群体。
就是理解问街为什么值这个钱的人。
相当于
因为我一会会把这个车举个例子。
当成是单炒饭
就是你不能说指着问街M9。
它那个单炒饭里面是有鲍鱼 海参。
是有这个澳洲龙虾的。
你现在的这个华进S。
它单炒饭就是个单炒饭。
它就是鸡蛋 葱花。
你最多喊老板给你多加点饭。
你让他再给你多放个蛋那是不可能的。
多放个蛋那是要加钱的。
所以两个客户群体它的诉求是不一样的。
是完全不一样的
你吃那个单炒饭加奥龙。
你其实本质是要吃奥龙。
不是吃单炒饭
这个吃单炒饭
它不是为了吃里面的蛋。
它是真的是要吃这个饭。
因为它饿了
只不过炒一下加个鸡蛋更香一点而已。
好
我们接着讲动力方面。
动力方面
华进S全息都是1.5T的插捧系统。
然后两具版本前电机是200千瓦。
316米
是单电机的
那么零百加速是8.5到8.6秒。
这个零百加速虽然说不像市面上动不动。
就是什么4秒多 5秒多 3秒多。
但是我告诉你8秒多对于一个电动车来讲。
也是足足够用了
你是不用担心的
你不能说它很快
但是我觉得家用它也不慢。
那么4具版本增加了一个186千瓦的后电机。
综合功率386千瓦。
综合扭矩能达到626米。
所以它零百加速就是5.2秒。
你要说5.2秒我能接受。
我要的就是那种就非一样的感觉。
好
一会我再给你讲
你要这个非一样的感觉。
那你的这个掏的钱也是非一样的感觉。
为什么这么讲呢？
就是从配置上来讲。
四区的定价我是觉得不合理的。
我就明确告诉你就是不合理的。
235千瓦四区乾坤。
尊相版
它的定价是203千8。
也就是它目前最顶的价格。
它的入门价格是200公里的越相版。
乾坤越相版159千8。
那么中间两个配置都是255公里的续航。
乾坤真相版和乾坤尊相版。
我的妈呀名字太绕了。
我的妈呀？
175千8 185千8差一万块钱。
好
我来给你讲一讲它的配置怎么选。
这四个版本还能再降一万。
因为我曾经讲过什么超级置换理。
你就理解为官方降价就可以了。
超级置换等于就是免费给钱给你。
你随便拿个行手证。
你去到厂家里面申报一下。
内部就给你瞬间秒过。
其实就是相真意义的。
对吧？
就给你去再让一万块钱。
那么因此它的真实的指导价应该是从14万9千8。
到19万3千8
所以它全都是一字头。
所以20.38万。
它其实不是它正常的一个售价。
19.38万才是正常的售价。
其实第一批定车的用户。
就是盲定的那一批。
其实还有一个优惠。
它应该都到不了19。
好
那我们讲这个配置怎么选。
首先入门版
它是31千瓦时
就是31度电的凌酸铁力电池。
它全息都是凌酸铁力。
但是这个31度电。
它的电星是来自于瑞普赛克。
它的CLTC纯电许行是200公里。
那么大家都知道CLTC就是吹拉唐唱。
对吧？
所以这个200公里的许行。
你再打个七折就140。
你要是在冬天打个对半折的话。
相当于就100公里左右。
所以你要能理解
那么这个也是它全息当中。
唯一非零德时代的电星的。
所以它许行会更短一点。
因为它度数也更小。
然后同时充电效率也会更低。
其他的三个版本
都是零德时代的凌酸铁力电星。
是41.9度电
比它的这个度数
就是多了差不多10度多一点。
那么两区版本的成电许行。
是255公里
CLTC四区版本因为多这个电机。
虽然说电视度数是一样的。
它的许行就是235公里。
所以我个人建议
你第一个Pass掉的这个版本。
就应该是最入门的14.98万的这个版本。
为什么呢？
因为你完全没必要。
你如果是正常级别的消费群体的话。
你多掏1万块钱掏不出来吗？
我都不用跟你去讲。
其他的一些舒适性的配置的差别。
包括它不带CDC。
因为除了这个版本。
其他配置都带CDC。
我就跟你讲电池度数变得更小。
然后同时电星的品牌不是零的时代。
就差这1万
你都不愿意去掏吗？
那就说明你可能就不是这个价位的消费群体。
我就建议你不要买这个车了。
你换其他的更便宜的设型。
你就不要硬上这种车长超5米2的大型的。
这种新的UISUV了。
好吧？
不要勉强
那么我多说两句
瑞普赛克
它是不是一个什么杂牌的电池呢？
其实也不是
瑞普它是瑞普蓝军。
赛克是柳州的赛克科技。
这个瑞普蓝军我曾经在我之前节目里面也介绍过。
我把国内目前头部的一些。
不管是一线的还是二线的电星的品牌。
电星的供应商
叫Sale供应商。
我都给大家全部介绍了一遍。
瑞普蓝军是青山石叶旗下的一个电池企业。
2017年成立的。
它的起家和总部都在浙江温州。
青山就是外界常说的世界孽王。
你听这个名字
不是中国孽王是世界孽王。
它的上游有涅矿
有掩念有材料的资源。
然后2025年
瑞普蓝军在国内的动力电池的总装车辆当中。
大概是排在第8
凌酸田里的装车辆大概是排在第7。
所以它是属于
就是在二线还能算是头部的。
在一线
可能稍微就是要往后烧一烧了。
二线算是头部的电池上。
所以它肯定不能算是杂牌。
全国也能排得到前十的。
但是品牌的影响力。
包括车用车的装机的规模。
和林德时代
包括像比亚迪
你甚至包括新网达。
国旋动力这些
肯定都是不能比的。
它不是一个级别的。
那么我们前面说的是瑞普蓝军。
那么我们今天讲的是瑞普赛克。
瑞普赛克它本身就是一个。
设在广西柳州的合资电信厂。
那么一听到合资
大家就明白了
两家公司
它是成立于2022年。
是瑞普蓝军它持股51%。
那么上期集团旗下的柳州赛克科技。
持股44%
2023年投产的。
投资大概差不多44亿的。
这样的一个投资
所以这么一讲
大家就很清楚了
说白了
其实就是自己公司。
就自己合资公司的电信。
去供给自己公司来用。
就这么理解
因为武林本身就属于上汽的。
上汽通用武林
所以它跟武林的关系非常的深。
但是严格来讲
它不是上汽通用武林直接控股的亲儿子。
因为直接控股的是瑞普蓝军。
它是跟上汽体系绑得非常深的。
这样的一个可以理解为。
跟瑞普蓝军共建的产业链合资公司。
是围绕着武林的需求。
在柳州旧境建厂
进行研发进行供货的这么一家公司。
那么另外还有一个容易搞混的地方。
就是有两家公司
一个叫做瑞普赛克。
一个叫做赛克瑞普。
你没有听错
就只不过是前后两个词。
调换了一下位置
但是这是两家不同的公司。
瑞普赛克主要就是造电信的。
赛克瑞普主要是做模组的。
是做park的电池包和电池系统的。
所以今后
大家如果看到一些汽车相关新闻的时候。
提到了瑞普赛克
你第一反应
广西、纽州跟上汽跟武林。
相关的这样的一家合资的做电信的公司。
如果是赛克瑞普
其实也是跟他们相关的。
只不过它不做电信。
是做模组park电视系统的。
反正不管怎么说
都是围绕着上汽通用武林。
在柳州的电池产业链。
这么理解就OK了。
所以这一段的题外话差得有点远。
我们再拉回来
我们刚刚是在说配置。
那么我们第一趴讲了就是最低配。
我是不推荐的
那么第二趴我想讲的是什么？
就是最顶配
它的价格定的是非常之不合理。
它的顶配价格定的是20万3千8。
刚刚前面说了
超级支换减1万19万3千8。
但是你要知道顶配的四区尊享版。
和它的两区尊享版。
就是两区顶配跟四区顶配。
17.58万和19.38万。
差了18000块钱。
价格差18000。
配置就差一个电机。
你觉得合理吗？
我觉得不合理
这个车的价格定的是很有性价比。
但是它的最顶配的价格。
它为什么定的这么不合理呢？
你说贵个8000块钱。
我觉得还行
我为了多一个电机。
动力体验 加速体验更好。
我可以接受
但是18000真的太离谱了。
你跟这个车的总价位来比的话。
也太离谱了
所以我觉得四区大概率是没什么人买。
就性价比一下就没有了。
对吧？
那么剩下来就是中间两个配置了。
就是两区中配跟两区的高配。
两区中配165008。
两区高配175008。
这两个版本怎么选呢？
我其实觉得你都已经是钱花到这个位置了。
而且这个车本身总价就不高。
定的价格也不贵
是吧？
你但凡不是说你的预算。
实在是顶到嗓子眼了。
你已经顶不住了
那么我建议你
这个1万块钱还是要加。
就是你要上到两区的顶配的。
这个175008的版本。
因为你加了这个1万块钱之后。
什么冷暖冰箱
小桌板
后排娱乐瓶
还有像一二排的座椅按摩。
这些东西都有了
你现在感觉说这些配置其实好像可有可无。
为什么你感觉可有可无。
因为你心疼的1万块钱。
你觉得可能要贷款。
你觉得说多1万块钱。
你每个月的压力会更大一点。
但是我告诉你
一般情况下
我不会让你去勾着1万块钱。
但你既然已经买到这个价位的车了。
而且这么大一个车子。
你平时肯定也是经常要出门。
要带着孩子
要满足后排的乘员的乘客的舒适度。
那你相信我
你如果是买了个中配。
你放弃了高配
你今后一定会掐自己的大腿。
你会非常的懊悔
因为这些东西
你基本上想再改你改不了。
你想后排娱乐瓶
做一按摩
对吧？
小桌板
哪怕就是改成本
你最后算了
你想当年我1万块钱。
原厂这些东西
冷暖冰箱这些东西都有。
我现在你不管改你一样东西。
都是几千块钱起步的。
而且改得不好
那后面你会更头疼。
好
我们接下来再讲
你说这个华晋S
这个车真正的核心卖点是什么呢？
那我觉得
你哪怕把它当成是一个。
卖的比较便宜的大型插缝SUV。
也是OK的
哪怕就是拿这个去比。
你不要去谈什么华为支架。
它放在同价位里面。
也是有一定的精灵力的。
但是你要让我总结下来的话。
我觉得整体来讲的话。
主要是四个卖点
那么第一个卖点就是价格跟尺寸。
是比较严重的一个错位。
因为不到15万
它入门价格149800。
那你就能买到一个车长超不明。
要轴距超3米1
第三排还正常能用的。
一个大溜走的新能源SUV。
那么你方言整个市场。
你就拿这些去比
你不用去看什么华为支架不支架。
你拿这个去比
其实本身可选的车型就不多。
讲来讲去
就我刚刚提面提到那几辆。
东风1008 零跑C16。
银河M9
那么这些算是竞品。
算是差不多加倍段的这些产品。
但是你去比下来
其实尺寸还是这个车最大。
然后空间可能差距不是那么明显。
但是你多多少少心理是有数的。
你轴距差个两三公分也好。
车的长度差个两三公分。
甚至更多也好
车身的宽度高度
它体量感也不一样。
说白了
华进S还是很能打。
这是第一点
第二点是什么呢？
就是它的核心卖点。
这个肯定不能不提。
它的核心卖点就是全系。
都是华为的智能化。
华为的这一套全家桶。
这个才是它的真正的杀手解。
有人讲说隔壁的蓝图。
其实也就是用了华为的这么一套全家桶。
但是这个蹭华为皮都快蹭破了。
天天都说华为华为华为。
就恨不得所有人提到蓝图就要想到华为。
那华进其实在宣传的过程当中。
我觉得相对来讲
还稍微克制一点
但是这个克制呢？
我觉得也只是刚开始。
因为它就一款车
蓝图给你感觉好像它饥喉口要退华为。
是因为蓝图它是非常密集的。
短时间内上了很多的一些新车。
你包括它原来的老版本的车型。
也都上了华为
所以它没什么可说的。
我上了这个车型
在我原来老版本的基础上改了什么？
那我改的不就是华为的东西吗？
那我不宣传华为我宣传什么呢？
所以你会觉得说
蓝图就感觉蹭华为蹭的皮都快蹭破了。
但是华进S 华进这个车系。
好像就不是那么的。
就是有点太极猴猴的要去告诉你。
我一定是华为的
其实并不是的
它潜移默化的
我觉得它相对比较高明一点。
它潜移默化的还是要告诉你。
我这个车最大的卖点其实就是华为。
它四个版本都是标配华为的。
乾坤ADS PRO的增强版支架。
那么这个支架呢？
我刚刚前面说了是仓力激光雷达。
然后呢有三颗毫米波的雷达。
还加上12颗的超级猫雷达和11颗的摄像头。
就全车传感器嘛？
那么它也是最新的鸿蒙坐舱。
然后这个车可以实现高速的NCA。
也可以实现成区的LCC。
还可以实现智能驳车。
这些都有的
那么有人讲了
不对啊？
它不是应该能实现成区的NCA吗？
这里我要提醒大家了。
它交付给你的时候。
就是你在指导价的基础上去买的时候。
它只是一个成区的LCC。
就是它不是领航辅助。
那么你想实现NCA的。
就是你设置个导航目的地领航辅助。
那对不起只要付钱的。
这是需要开通的
开通的价格是多少钱呢？
12000买断
你也可以按约定嘛？
但是我觉得我身边没有人按约定。
肯定是直接买断
买断12000现在给你一个券6000块钱。
那么你只要再付6000就可以了。
要实际的开通价格6000块。
所以这个要不要开肯定是要开的。
为什么？
因为硬件你已经花钱买了。
你说我为了省着6000块钱。
我告诉你
你省你早晚也是要花钱买的。
你现在不花钱买
你现在你车子你能用几年。
我就算你用五年
你忍了一年没买
那你其实又损失了一年的体验嘛？
那你不如车子还没出4S店。
赶紧就给它开了嘛？
你买这个车你就把这个预算给加上。
硬件你已经有了
你没有软件开通
你体验缺失
你反而更亏
你听我的
所以你买这个车要加6000块钱。
就肯定是要加的
任何一个版本都要加6000块钱。
所以你要知道买这种车型。
买华为系的车型
不是说车子买回去啥也不用管。
想体验完整的支架还是要掏钱的。
好这是第二个卖点。
那么第三个卖点是什么呢？
就是这个底盘
底盘其实它也没有什么很高科技的东西。
也没有什么800V什么全主动全价。
什么48V全主动全价。
没有
它也用不起这么贵的东西。
用了肯定价格就不是这样的嘛？
但是这个全价呢？
它全系是前双XB。
然后全系都是后连感。
除了入门碗之外
都是有CDC连续可变阻力减人气。
那么它没有空旋
也没有互轮转向
在这个价位里面
你要想加这些东西的话。
那对不起
这个价格肯定要再往上提一提。
你想这个价位这里提1万。
那里提5000
那就不是我们讲14万多起售了。
是不是
它的轮圈全系都是圈胎21英寸的。
2645 21
全系都是它也部分高配和低配。
所以我觉得50就是量大管宝。
该给你的
反正我也不给你高低配。
还要给你分个什么20寸19寸的。
全是21
但是这里面你要注意一点。
圈胎的尺寸是一样的。
但是品牌不一样
它的两区跟四区的顶配。
都是用的米其林PS4。
就是新能源的SUV就是专用胎。
它是那种精英胎
这个胎还是比较贵的。
就是单条胎的市面上的售价。
差不多1300-1500。
那么厂家肯定不是按照这个价格来进的。
但是我只想告诉你成本是比较高的。
是好胎
那么其他版本配的就相对普通一点的胎了。
肯定是没有米其林的PS4的胎好嘛？
对吧？
那么这是第三个点。
第四个点是什么呢？
就是它的卖点
其实主要还是相对配置功能是比较丰富的。
也比较舍得给配置。
全系标配的都是前后双层隔音玻璃。
就是我们俗称的双层加腰玻璃嘛？
那么15.6英寸的2K的中控屏都是有的。
也不分什么大尺寸小尺寸。
然后鸿蒙坐舱标配的。
15个扬声器标配的。
还有什么电动尾门。
翻摩盘加热
50W的无线充电这些都有。
那么到了中高配
它还会再给你一二排的通风加热按摩座椅。
还有8.8升的0到50度的这样的一个冷暖冰箱。
这里面要注意它是零度。
不是零下
零度其实有一点凉。
零下是可以有那种小冰珠子了。
难道零下12度的话。
那么零下12度就可以去。
相当于是把这个冰棒放进去冰棍放进去。
它是不会融化
甚至于你把一个
就是比方说发水放在里面。
它是能动成冰的
但是这里面你要注意。
里面你要冷藏还是要冷冻。
你这一定要搞清楚。
你不能同时冷冻又冷藏。
所以我觉得零下6度的。
这样的一个就是保持。
就体感比较凉
上面有一层小水珠的。
这种状态是最好的。
零度有一点凉
其实也错过着能用。
那么就总比那种
就是不是压缩机的版本要好吧？
东风一派的冰箱
它就不是压缩机的。
像这个就是带压缩机的。
其他版本的像银河的M9。
像包括像这个车
它都是带压缩机的。
那么带压缩机的这个呢？
我再给大家提个醒。
因为现在像上次我们去试大堂的时候。
大堂的工程师跟我讲说。
他们现在已经是把压缩机前置。
就是跟空调压缩机是共用。
他们用了一个自己的新的技术。
那么因此你在车内休息的时候。
如果冰箱你也不想关。
那你就不会听到冰箱压缩机启动的声音。
这一点很重要
你如果习惯性的在车内5岁的话。
那么你一定要搞清楚。
就是你的冰箱关还是不关。
如果你的冰箱不关。
那么你的冰箱的压缩机是不是在车内。
如果在车内它一旦要是开启。
声音还是比较大的。
因为在比方说地下车库这种绝对安静的环境里面。
你人又是坐在车子里面去躺着休息。
你这个如果是在前排。
你这老门啊正好就是。
正好就在那个中间的扶手旁边一点点。
你想一想就听得非常的清楚。
这个一定要注意
然后呢这个后排的屏幕。
细顶屏
包括电动调节第三排。
这都是中高配才有的。
然后还有一个就是。
它的后背箱里面会有电动调节后排这个功能。
所以你的后背箱如果经常要去调整。
它的容积
那这个功能是非常的关键。
所以我觉得选高配的还是会更多一点。
真的
所以你要是单看这个配置的丰富程度。
你放在这个同级边里面来看。
也是相当能打的
所以我觉得华静S这个车子。
你要问我它核心的卖点是什么？
就这四个嘛？
一看就很明白了
就这四个
你比来比续就是绕不开这四个点嘛？
那么我们接下来再讲一讲。
就是买这个车需要注意什么？
也就是它有一些配置啊？
有一些地方是不是有缺失。
那么我们前面讲到这个车没有空旋。
没有空旋能对你有什么影响呢？
我觉得也没什么太多影响。
除非你之前开的就是空旋的车。
你觉得说我现在离不开空旋。
我就要那种很舒服的。
就是隔离感很强的这样的一种加乘的感受。
那你就出门左拐
去买有空旋的车
那么还有就是没有后轮转向。
没有后轮转向这个我觉得很简单。
你只要在单马路上原地吊个头。
你感受一下
就是没有后轮转向。
你是一把能吊过来还是不能吊过来。
如果不能吊过来
你稍微揉一把方向往后倒一点。
是不是就能过
这个你心里面有个底就行了。
对吧？
我觉得也不至于说没有后轮转向。
你车都不会开了吧？
是不是
然后这个车全系没有HOD。
也没有电吸门
也没有流媒体后视镜。
也没有前后的可开启的天窗。
它的天应该叫天幕。
它的天幕是分断式的。
是不可开启的
所以这一点你要注意。
然后它内后视镜甚至于都是手动防穴幕的。
所以这一块都是节省成本的。
而且我想告诉你就是连选都选不了。
选不了装没有选装。
那当然了
价位摆在这
你不能要求那么高。
所以我想给大家提个醒。
就是在武林的体系里面看车。
你要摆正自己的一个心态。
就不是说
人民需要什么武林就造什么？
那武林就造什么？
不是代表说武林什么都给你啊？
对不对
那武林又不是福利院。
它为什么什么都要满足你。
它不是你妈
那你为什么要找武林。
因为你没有钱
你又想要
只有武林能给你造。
就这么简单一个道理嘛？
但是武林只能解决你的刚须。
不能满足你的欲望。
我曾经也讲过
这个刚须和欲望代表什么？
你渴了要喝水
你不喝水
你要渴死
你饿了要吃饭
你不吃饭
你要饿死
这叫刚须
但是你说你渴了
要喝可乐
你饿了要吃汉堡
但是你兜里面喝可乐只有一块钱。
吃汉堡只有三块五块。
那那那你这就叫欲望。
你就是你的实际的收入跟你的欲望。
你不匹配
对吧？
你的收入能解决刚须解决不了欲望。
所以你心态一定要调整好。
武林不是说你什么？
你那个叫许愿望
你知道吧？
你这不是欲望
你都是许愿望了
那武林只能是满足你刚须。
对吧？
你的欲望你的愿望。
它不一定能给你实现。
所以心态一定要摆正。
其实我感觉武林已经帮很多人。
许多愿都还了愿了。
真的
因为很多人当年肯定就是这么许愿的。
我真的我希望有一辆。
车长超过5米2的。
大六座的新能源SUV。
最好还是能有华为的支撑支架。
最好只卖个十十几万。
对吧？
你讲十几万的时候。
你心里面都没有底。
因为你脑子里面想的是问解M9。
那车都卖四五十万五六十万。
十几万
结果人家武林跟华为合作之后给你糟出来了。
华静S它给你实现了。
好
实现之后你再看到这个车。
你开始吐槽
你说你就贴个保军的标。
你的保军卖个将近二十万。
这个时候开始二十万了。
对吧？
看顶配的价格了
二十万
买个保军二十万
是不是有点过分了。
连空气悬挂都没给。
连后轮转向都没给。
你觉得是武林过分了。
华静过分了
还是你过分了
我觉得你都不是来买车的。
你是来抢劫的
你是
华静S
它就像是一碗蛋炒饭。
你如果鸡肠鹿鹿
饿得两眼放光
你兜里面又没有几块钱。
你就赶紧在路边摊。
你就坐下来
让老板给你炒碗饭。
你就别讲究了
你饭里面如果能挑出两根肉丝。
我觉得你都得夸老板两句。
这可能是上一个肉丝炒面的。
碗它没刷干净
锅没刷干净
对吧？
有的时候我们会遇到这种情况。
肉丝炒面留了两根肉丝在里面。
下一个就是蛋炒饭。
你就夸它是良心老板了。
对吧？
前面一个客户给你露下来的。
所以这个车就是这么个车。
但是有的人还是想研究一下。
说这个华静起静易静。
它跟华为之间到底是什么样的一个合作关系。
是不是一样的
那当然不是了
起静易静是华为乾坤官方共创的一个品牌。
它对外的标识就是。
华为乾坤起静
华为乾坤易静
它是华为深度参与定义的一个品牌。
而这个华静它本质上。
它仍然还是武林体系里面的产品品牌。
所以可以理解为
起静易静是华为跟它一起参与。
相当于开了一个饭店。
然后门头你就可以打上。
华为乾坤起静大饭店。
华为乾坤易静大饭店。
但是华静你是不可以。
就是在门头上挂任何跟华为相关的东西。
而且整个店的装修啊？
包括这个怎么怎么摆饭怎么设计啊这些。
甚至包括华为的厨子也不可能入住进来啊对吧？
这些都不行
它相当于只是开了一个饭店。
是武林自己
武林集团
然后呢叫武林华静大饭店。
只能叫武林华静大饭店。
你不能跟华为有关系。
但你可以宣传什么呢？
你可以说
我们这个整个厨房是华为提供的智能化厨房。
你看隔壁的那个起静还有易静。
他们的厨房跟我们的厨房。
标准是一模一样的。
咱们用的都是一套。
华为的智能化厨房的这个方案。
你可以这么宣传是没有问题的。
那么剩下来的就是看你怎么说了嘛对吧？
你说经常华为的人也到我们这边来吃饭。
给我们指点指点
你要这么说也行
对吧？
给我们指点指点
但是也有小道消息讲说。
其实后期华静也是要跟华为在深度合作。
怎么个深度法
是不是要把这个合作模式再升级一下。
走一步看一步
因为毕竟确实都是静自卑的。
但是这个合作模式又不一样。
外境又会有些误解。
不如华为干脆就破格力。
对吧？
就把它收进来算了。
合作模式往上伸一伸。
行不行
这个还是需要两边来谈。
还是需要两边来谈。
那么好
现在大家都知道了。
这两者之间是什么区别。
那么我想问
你知道这个区别之后。
对于你买不买华静S有什么影响吗？
毫无影响
因为买华静S的人。
从来就没有把它当成任何的静。
或者说是去对比任何的界。
就是大家只把它当成什么？
当成是拥有华为智能化技术的。
武灵旗舰SUV而已。
就说到底这台车最吸引你的既不是武灵。
也不是华静
而是你现在能用156万的预算。
就买到过去三四十万。
你才敢想的这么一款车。
你想想是不是这么一个事。
就这么一个事嘛？
对不对
你别说三四十万了。
就你以前四五十万才敢想的这么一辆车。
你现在156万就能实现了。
虽然说可能从细节品质上。
你跟那个四五十五六十万的问解M9你比不了。
但是毕竟你看我也有华为智价了。
我也有华为的智苍了。
是不是
我空间也不比它差多少。
但是我价格比你便宜。
我三分之一的价格。
好
那么最后再讲一讲。
华静S它到底是属于华静。
还是属于保俊品牌。
因为网上天天都有人在争论。
其实真这个我觉得也没什么意义。
因为现在官方已经非常明确了。
就是要把华静这个品牌独立出来。
我前面节目一开头我就开始讲了。
但是现在这个车又是挂着保俊的标。
那么官方也没有讲的那么细。
就是说咱们正在商讨。
有可能我们在今年的四季度。
或者说在今后
我们要去给它进行换标。
因为独立之后再换个标。
那就跟保俊这个品牌就完全脱离了。
就是完全就是分离开。
但是你觉得会有人去在乎这个东西吗？
有人会去研究这个品牌吗？
我觉得无论它今后是沿用保俊的标也好。
还是说启用一个新的车标也好。
在买家的眼里面
这就是武林造的有华为技术的车。
就是我前面讲的那个。
就是它相当于是有华为技术的武林旗舰SUV。
就这么简单
我们回头再讲
你说保俊当年也是想往高端上面走一走。
价格至少也想往上卖一卖。
也出了很多的车型。
为什么保俊的价格一直卖不上去。
很多人一看保俊卖这个价。
心里面总是觉得说有一点点。
怎么讲呢？
就是值不值
其实它卖的也很便宜了。
它跟同级的竞亭比车的空间也很大。
配置也很高
但是大家总是觉得说。
我在隔壁的武林我来看看。
你同样的这个大小空间。
有没有武林的车在卖。
而且有的时候两家店。
它这个展厅都是打通的。
你左手看着保俊
你右手就能去看武林。
甚至销售两面都同时在卖。
还能遇到这种事
所以大家就觉得说。
你说我买保俊的意义是什么呢？
感觉没有把档次上跟武林拉开。
对吧？
那保俊是不是就属于更加时尚一点的武林呢？
好
那么现在大家怎么去看华境呢？
你认为说华境就把武林体系的。
整体价格的天花板。
就往上拉了
捅破天花板了吗？
它现在上的这辆车已经是一个5米2的。
超过5米2大型的SUV。
那么这个车的价格就已经定的这么低了。
它今后还准备用什么车。
再来去突破它的天花板。
再去定高价
所以我跟你说
这台车子
它相当于就是一个含华量更高一点的武林造的车。
所以绝大多数消费者也不会给予说。
华境这个品牌能够多么高的一个溢价的空间。
多么高的一个溢价的心理预期。
所以你想将来你想把价格卖高。
我觉得可能进不大。
因为你首先现在华境S第一款车。
就已经是这么大型的SUV。
插谎SUV才卖145万这样一个价。
对吧？
就已经是地板价了。
你还谈什么天花板了。
所以华境它属不属于独立品牌。
华境S属不属于华境还是属于保俊。
经过华境到底换不换标。
根本就不重要
它的整个的价格的框架基本上已经。
在这一款车上市之后就已经框死了。
我认为就已经框死了。
它今后能腾挪的空间就那么大。
它不管出多少款车。
基本上你到了比方说。
有人讲能不能出个不到5米的4米9的车。
好 你出个4米9的车卖多少钱。
你5米2的华境S才这个价。
你4米9卖多少钱。
你将来再出一个什么4米6。
4米7紧速型的SUV卖多少钱。
你再出一个将近5米的较车卖多少钱。
这个价格体系其实当这一款车华境S上市的时候。
不都已经基本上矿定了吗？
你还能让这个品牌说兼付什么充更高端的一个使命。
我觉得这完全没必要。
完全没必要
这个品牌只要充销量就可以了。
其实我感觉
华境S其实更应该是直接就干脆把宝俊给剃掉了。
还留个宝俊干嘛呢？
是不是相当于就是宝俊转型新能源或者说宝俊含华之后。
摇身一变就成了华境S。
这不挺好的吗？
还留着那些宝俊的车干嘛呢？
直接全部上华为的这一套全家统。
然后全部华规到华境的体系里面。
然后销量全部起飞。
那不挺好吗？
搞那么多品牌干什么的一点意义都没有。
你除非说你还想留着燃油车。
把以前5.0的油车再换个标。
变成宝俊的车
然后宝俊再给它稍微的装修的精致一点。
再去打个叉价去卖一卖油车。
你宝俊你就不要碰新能源。
你就跟5.0做一个小小的这种定位差。
你们俩就去折腾燃油车去。
然后把新能源就全部丢给华规。
这个也是OK的
但是我更建议就是。
那你不如宝俊直接就不要了。
留着干嘛呢？
就直接转接新能源吧？
5.0就卖家用车。
你就要人民需要什么5.0就造什么？
就绝对极致性价比。
咱们也不在意是不是5.0的标。
如果但凡是要新能源车想要家用车。
直接看华规多简单呀？
对不对
哎呀怎么讲呢？
其实也不用讲的那么绕。
其实一句话总结华规S身份确实有点小复杂。
但是华规S这个产品的定义。
其实一点都不复杂。
华规S现在就是一台。
品牌想独立
车标还没独立
渠道想独立
店面还没独立
技术用了华规
但是身份又不是鸿蒙自行的车。
但是这个车你要问我说值不值得买。
我觉得是值得买的。
你不用在意什么身份。
不身份背景不就背景的。
小姐你也不用那么绕。
我刚刚讲的有点绕。
其实这个车它就是5.0体系里面。
目前智能化程度最高。
而在华规体系里面。
性价比又是最高的车。
就这么简单
好的那么以上就是本期节目的主要内容。
给大家收听
在喜马拉雅小宇宙。
如果听到这没订阅的兄弟姐妹。
其实可以动动发辖的小手指点一下订阅。
订阅之后每周三每周六更新会有提醒。
那么在喜马拉雅收听的朋友们。
如果方便的话
在手机播放页面小三角下方。
有免费的月票可以帮我投一投。
你听30分钟就可以领一张免费月票。
对吧？
我的节目都已经40多分钟了。
你如果不投的话
也反正放在那边也是早晚要过期。
感谢大家
非常感谢
那么在每期节目的留言区。
我们会抽三位在下期节目进行互动。
那么会赠送由人言计提供的。
苹果翠两包
非常好吃
如果想买的话
包括我们的摆车全收的周边。
你要想买
也可以上小程序搜索摆车全说。
就可以看到我们的商城了。
好的上期节目咱们聊的是。
放弃小米预期
直接RX买追光S。
就是蓝图的追光S到底值不值。
我感觉很多人对这个社还挺感兴趣的。
而且很多人对这个社还挺了解的。
那么其中有一段我讲到关于。
像我之前的Avita 11。
从ADS4能不能升到ADS5。
我了解的就是不能升。
它哪怕就是把我的版本升到ADS5。
和目前市面上那些乾坤支架的ADS5。
也不完全一样
那么我看到有两位提出了一些质疑。
那么其中一位叫做不想加班的工程师。
他是这么讲
他说刀哥的节目听了很久了。
几乎每期都投了月票。
刀哥也很专业
非常感谢
你明显就是先扬后意。
对吧？
你先夸我两句
让我后面你的批评能够接受。
他说有一个地方我需要指证。
就是关于2024年以后的车辆。
才能升级Viva 2.0的说法。
其实不对的
问解M5
还有问解M7
它的辅助驾驶的版本。
其实是发布在2023年的。
那么根据最新的OTA公告。
也是可以升级ADS5。
也就是Viva的2.0。
那么另外我自己也是辅助驾驶M5的车主。
那么车其实开起来还可以。
就是感觉整体产品力也有一些过时了。
那么希望刀哥以后也能多聊一聊。
早期活梦之行的车辆的一些细节。
祖三刀的栏目越办越好。
你看这果然是工程师。
而且是一个情商非常高的工程师。
所以我觉得你肯定是事业有成。
你如果很年轻的话。
那我觉得你前途会非常的光明。
真的
你听你讲话
看你的文字的组织就能看得出来。
你包括跟领导说话。
一定也是先考虑领导的感受。
然后再先扬后翼
这是比较小心谨慎地提出自己的一些想法。
的确这一块其实我没有做交叉验证。
我是通过AI了解了一下。
然后在网上我也搜了一下。
看了一下相关信息。
这块信息我改天还是要去跟厂家。
就是华为这一块的工程师。
去具体了解一下
哪些车型是不是就已经是不能升级到ADS-5了。
还是说哪些年份或者是硬件软件哪一方面。
可能相对复杂一点。
而且不止你一位
还有一位挺有
也是我们的重讲留言。
他在小宇宙留言
叫K-O-Y-O-U-N-G。
空样
他说道哥你别吓我。
我记得阿维塔在公开的场合都宣布过。
说阿维塔全系都可以升级ADS-5的。
说如果ADS-5不能升的话。
那感觉要亏死
他说还有就是
我再补充一点
我说的换架构是硬件架构是可以换的。
也就是说当前的这一套MDC控制器里面。
是可以装最新的ADS-5软件的。
没有任何的问题
然后他还说他当年去看阿维塔。
就是因为听到了我开的就是阿维塔。
然后最后看完他就把这个车给定了。
他还提醒我说道哥。
阿维塔11马上又停产了。
停产就停产了
历史使命已经完成了。
对吧？
反正这车开的也挺好的。
我最近这几年也不会卖。
反正目前来讲就陪孩子上学嘛？
等把这几年初中几年高中度过之后。
等孩子上了大学了。
我们再考虑后面怎么样切换一下我的人生模式。
退休模式
好
行
感谢二位听友对于我的关于就是。
华为支架升级这一块的一些不同的补充。
回头我也要去跟官方去交叉认证一下。
我再把最新的消息跟大家在节目里面去分享。
那么下面最后一位听友。
他的名字叫做周晨乒乓。
周晨是他的名字
然后我看他的那个头像应该是乒乓教练吧？
我看他的那个样子是挺专业的。
难道是乒乓球运动员。
然后他说三刀有一个观点。
我很不认同
就是那个关于临终立作业的布局。
你要知道不是所有的老婆都是喜欢坐在后排的。
我老婆大夏天令愿晒太阳也要坐在我的旁边。
那么如果儿子在的话。
儿子会坐在我的旁边。
老婆坐在后面
还有就是比如说刚结婚的小两口。
他们也不会分开来前后座的。
也都是主妇家坐在一起。
当然他说我讲的是关系比较好。
关系不好的也坐在一起的。
我知道
还有就是他说家里面如果有老人。
老人也是喜欢坐在前面。
跟我们年轻人唠唠嗑啥的。
他说我猜你老婆平时可能不太依赖你。
你在家里的地位也是排在最后。
所以每一次一家人出门都会把你去当司机。
还有你平时在家话可能也不少说。
罗罗巴说的
车子一开起来他们坐在后排。
就不想跟你讲话
你一个人在前面这样话就能少一点。
他说刀哥我说的对吗？
我这一次可是把所有的月票都给了你。
这个就跟前面那个工程师就相反。
这个是先易后扬
当然把我当兄弟跟我开开玩笑都很正常。
你猜的对吗？
我觉得你猜的一半对一半不对。
这里面我觉得有几点是我们两家不太一样的。
首先你家是儿子我家是女儿。
这两种家庭的乡主模式本来就不太一样。
而且你看我
看你是个什么乒乓球培训。
不知道是你打乒乓球特别好或者怎样。
你肯定跟你儿子应该都打乒乓球。
所以你们俩老子带儿子是有很多共同爱好的。
至少是在运动方面。
老爸带着儿子去训练打乒乓聊比赛。
所以你跟他两个人坐在一起。
而且我不知道你年龄。
你儿子如果超过12岁才能做副驾。
你儿子如果没超过12岁你做副驾是违法的。
兄弟
你千万不能说没超12。
你就做副驾
你们两副子两个人坐在副驾。
你有很多的话题可以聊。
我刚刚前面说了
对吧？
你如果你是搞乒乓球培训的。
我不知道我说的对吗？
你能不能评论这告诉我。
我说的对不对
我猜的对不对
还有就是家里面
你要知道女儿是老爸的小明儿。
但是女儿是老妈的闺蜜。
他们俩就真的是像闺蜜一样。
而且我女儿青春妻。
你想想看
他们两个人无话不谈。
真的是无话不谈
你说什么孩子青春妻叛逆。
我们家有的时候吵起架来确实挺叛逆。
但是平时都是正常人。
还是很正常
跟老爸聊天也正常。
跟老妈聊天也正常。
他跟他妈话很多
非常多
所以两个人平时还有很多悄悄话。
女儿也会跟他妈妈吐槽一些学校的事。
吐槽的学校的老师同学讲很多八卦。
有些事情他也会跟我讲。
我跟他聊得更多的。
就是网上的一些梗。
游戏动漫小说什么这些那些的。
因为我也是搞自媒体的。
有些东西我懂的还比他多。
是吧？
所以说他跟他妈妈聊得更多的是。
包括什么化妆
然后服装搭配这些。
因为我家女儿现在也是喜欢Cost。
然后他化妆也让他妈教他。
所以他们之间什么画画舞蹈这些东西。
话题很多我参与不了。
我根本参与不了
所以他们自然而然就形成闺蜜了。
上车之后两个小闺蜜做后排。
这不很正常吗？
是不是他不可能抛下他妈。
坐在我的车的副驾的。
然后跑到副驾干嘛呀？
专门陪老爸一边开车一边聊天。
开车聊天也不安全。
是不是
而且他的年龄还有个关键问题。
就是年龄
他现在才刚刚满一三的话。
才刚满十三岁
他去年其实才十二。
十二周岁以下是不允许做副驾的。
所以我也不知道周凶宁家孩子多大。
如果不到十二岁千万不能做副驾。
你说那为什么老婆不能做副驾呢？
如果是我跟老婆两个人单独出门。
那他肯定是做副驾。
哪有夫妻两个人单独出门。
老婆还不做副驾
我觉得夫妻关系就不正常了。
你哪怕就是出于夫妻之间基本的礼仪。
你太阳再晒你也要坐在副驾。
这个正常的
你说我跟我妈出门。
老人出门肯定也是做前排。
毫无疑问不用想的嘛？
对不对
如果是一家四口老婆孩子做后排。
我妈肯定也是做副驾。
也是一起聊天的嘛？
而且还有一点就是我的副驾一直都比较乱。
因为我节目里面曾经给大家讲过嘛？
我会把垃圾袋夹在手套箱那个位置。
然后同时我的副驾的坐垫上面。
经常会有些东西
有的时候是遮阳散。
夏天天比较热
我会把遮阳散随手就放在副驾的这个坐垫上面。
还有的时候会有一些小背包。
还有的时候公司拿的一些东西。
没来得及拿到家里面。
我会扔在副驾上面。
还有反正乱七八糟的一些东西。
所以我老婆有的时候她也想做副驾。
一拉开车门乱七八糟的。
就像我刚刚讲的
如果我们两个人出门。
我还要专门把副驾的这个脚底下收拾一下。
坐垫收拾一下放在后排。
她才能上车
所以这就是怎么讲的用车方式不同。
然后就是家里面
你上儿子我是女儿。
这个陪伴的方式也不同。
共同爱好
差异比较大
但是这不能说什么家里面的地位高低。
我觉得大家都是平等的。
但你要说具体你调侃我。
你说刀哥你在家里面地位是不是比较低。
那确实是的
我在家里面地位可能都不如我们家的狗。
但是不管怎么说对吧？
一家人合合募募
幸幸福福开开心心的就行了。
无所谓做哪有什么在意这些东西的。
又不是跟领导吃饭。
还要排座次啥的
其实这件事情重点。
咱们还是聊到临终力座椅。
你想说的就是前排两个临终力座椅的使用频率到底高不高。
其实前排两个临终力座椅。
我还是那个话
主驾肯定是最高的。
副驾你指望说长期有人用。
我还是那个观点
我是觉得副驾不是特别高。
标配的意义不是特别大。
所以也不能拿你作为一个案例去分析。
也不能拿我作为一个案例去分析。
这个东西就是厂家取舍的问题。
无非还是成本
还是成本
所以产品最好是给用户进行选择。
而不是说替每个家庭去规定说。
到底谁应该做这儿。
谁应该做那儿
为什么我给了你这个功能。
你不做在这儿你不去用。
那是你自己浪费这功能。
对吧？
你不按常规去做
不能这么说
行吧？
那么以上就是三条留言互动。
感谢大家的收听
那么如果想要参与留言互动。
就是在每期节目去进行评论。
那么下一期我会抽其中三条。
每一条会赠送由人言计提供的。
苹果翠两包
那么怎么领奖呢？
就是联系盾牌
盾牌的微信46415254。
如果想要跟我一对一的交流。
也可以加这样一个微信。
46415254。
想进入社群也可以加这个微信。
也可以关注我们的订阅号。
摆车全说
那么还有就是我的个人微博。
摆车全说三刀
以及我的短视频账号。
三刀砍车
单人旁砍大山的砍。
在抖音视频号小红书。
快手都可以搜
还有就是我的Bilibili的账号。
也叫摆车全说
那么今天这期节目就到这里。
我们下一期接着聊。
拜拜